merci c'est le premier ministre la
parole est à monsieur paul salen pour
les républicains
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre monsieur
le premier ministre les chiffres du
chômage du mois d'octobre ont été
dévoilés la semaine dernière et avec
tristesse nous avons encore appris
qu'ils avaient quarante deux mille
chômeurs supplémentaires soit une hausse
de 3,7 en a aujourd'hui deux mille neuf
cent mille français sont au chômage soit
10,6 de la population active avec des
variantes très importante en fonction
des territoires
d'une manière générale les anciens
département industriel du nord et de
l'est ainsi que ceux du sud est sont les
plus touchés le chômage continue de
progresser dans le pays alors qu'il
recule chez une grande partie de nos
voisins à 6g notre voisin allemand le
taux de chômage est de 6% son plus bas
niveau depuis la réunification
je pense que ceci est dû à la deuxième
position que notre pays occupe en
matière des prélèvements obligatoires
les plus élevés parmi les pays
développés avec 45 2% du pib
pire la plus forte progression du
chômage
sargis chez les moins de 25 ans avec un
point de plus sur trois mois au lieu de
0 20 dans les autres catégories d'âge
pourtant pourtant la jeunesse était
censé être une priorité de votre
majorité comme moi monsieur le premier
league je suis sûr que vous pensez que
cette fois ci c'en est trop le ppe-de
embauches qui a eu lieu s'effectue
aujourd'hui ans s'est aidée car les
employeurs ont des craintes quant à la
bouche de salariés sur le long terme en
raison du poids des charges en raison de
l'évolution économique incertaine et en
raison aussi de l'instabilité des règles
et des normes
monsieur le premier ministre que confère
au gouvernement pour répondre coup
france et à l'inquiétude le compatriote
en matière d'emploi
face à la menace terroriste que nous
subissons vous avez déclenché et avec
raison une riposte de grande ampleur
pourquoi ne pas faire de même contre le
chômage et quand grain nos territoires
et devient un véritable fléau pour notre
société
merci monsieur débuté la parole est à
madame la mini
du travail de l'emploi de la formation
professionnelle et du dialogue social
merci ma la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
bien évidemment les chiffres du mois
dernier n'était pas satisfaisant et en
effet pour combattre le chômage il faut
deux préalables
le premier c'est la croissance elle est
là elle est au delà de nos prévisions
mais elle n'est pas suffisante
en effet pour compenser l'an les entrées
dans le marché du travail qui sont
importants dans notre pays
le deuxième préalable c'est que
l'économie crée de l'emploi aujourd'hui
le climat des affaires est meilleur mais
pas suffisant en effet également et les
emplois qui sont créés sont des emplois
en intérim ou des emplois en cdd courts
ce qui explique les mouvements de
basculer variations très forte que nous
avons d'un mois à l'autre
face à ce constat aujourd'hui le
gouvernement est particulièrement
mobilisée à la fois sur l'enjeu des
emplois non pourvus
il est faux de croire que dans notre
pays il y aurait huit cent mille emplois
non pourvus
comme je peux entendre parfois je
considère qu'un emploi de deux heures
par semaine et patins emplois non
pourvus mais en effet il y à 200 milles
à 300000 emplois non pourvus dans notre
pays
dans l'hôtellerie la restauration dans
la métallurgie dans l'industrie qui sont
pour moi aujourd'hui sur lequel nous
devons impérativement répondre
pour cela il faut améliorer à la fois
les formations en direction de ce public
c'est le plan 100000 formation nous
avions fait l'an dernier et sur ce plan
là ce plan axé en direction des
demandeurs d'emploi a particulièrement
porté des résultats puisque c'est près
de 60 % des demandeurs d'emploi derrière
qui trouvent un emploi durable
pour cela nous avons le président de la
république l'a annoncé il aura 150 mille
formation prioritaire l'an prochain
deuxième sujet nous avons un chômage de
peu ou pas qualifiés la garantie jeunes
la garantie jeunes que nous avons mis du
temps à mettre en oeuvre mais qui
aujourd'hui généralisé
trente mille jeunes cette année près de
60 mille entrées l'an prochain 95 % qui
sont pas en emploi pas en formation pas
en éducation
elle est ingérée l'as blainville liste
et nous permettra justement de renforcer